so over have you submitted your chapter
five submissions without any punctuation
which was sort of surprising but then
also very obvious for this time period
that we're all living in than the way we
communicate on a normal and natural
level and siding with gray say it's
Friday with grace cuz I really don't
want to write this whole thing by myself
it's writing with grace writing with me
me my name is Grace welcome to another
episode of writing with grace I am grace
you write I was starving oh look I'm
back with my favorite flat shell and my
favorite prop I wasn't calling you a
flash elf let's call myself a flash elf
whatever let's dive right into this
episode with some this week over 20% of
your facebook comments are about how
much you like my sweater from last
week's episode I'm glad that you guys
are staying on message we have a winner
in our Harry and Marmee ship name I
conducted a poll on my Twitter and with
76% of the vote the winner is har me
who doesn't want a ship name that's both
adorable and dangerous here's a fun stat
this week over 70% of your comments on
our chapter 5 prompt page we're plugging
your own Wattpad pages I appreciate a
good muscle now let's move on to our
superlatives the award for best talking
this week goes to user secret NRB secret
NRB wrote a really hilarious chapter
Harry was just real dumb at texting and
some of his text messages were no poorly
written and this is by far my favorite
one anyone knows how T a plea for dance
school he wants to dance you guys
there's an avenue worth exploring the
award for best surprise surprise this
week goes to
user Mara Jade Allah or Margit daya
this user decided to make mr. Kevin's
ex-wife bananas mom and somehow both mr.
Kevin and banana had no idea I mean I'd
like to meet that lady talk about a real
hustle Wow impressive and sad she must
be so unfulfilled moving on they were
this week for best prom cries goes to
use their hand holster they have decided
that on day five of freak week the weird
environmental shift is that the
autocorrect on the group text messaging
is Auto correcting how each character
actually thinks and feels just mine
that's why I'm so terrified of AI
because that could actually happen I
know for this week's choice chapter our
chapter 5 choice chapter goes to user
bran muffin two or three now this week I
asked you guys to create a chapter based
solely on a group text message whoa
group text they must have some really
great cell service to maintain that
kinda texting am i right
a T&G bran muffin 23 decided that on day
five of freak week everyone's emotions
are affected by the level of light that
is happening in the school when the
lights are bright everyone is very
excited about everything but when the
lights are dim everyone is very sad and
depressed and dark in more ways than one
about everything so I've got the chapter
to the constant fluctuation of light and
darkness
okay this chapter is about life uh-oh
there are a lot of amazing one-liners in
this chapter
Marmee for instance is thoroughly
obsessed with her bowel movements
throughout this entire piece banana okay
team let's split up and look for clues
to confirm mr. Kay's the hacker lace we
should form pairs like for example um I
don't know Marmee and Harry's Marmee
hard pass which coincidentally also
describes my experience in the loo the
morning after I've ingested too much
cheese there's a ton of other great
one-liners in the chapter make sure you
go read them all so they have decided to
name the mysterious hacker robot voice
Loudmouth
because Harry doesn't understand how
intercoms work and thought that someone
was just yelling very loudly to them
throughout the school every time we
heard that mysterious voice over the
intercom so now we have loud mouths as
our mysterious evil villain also on this
group text crush drops a huge spoiler
about Jim having already known loud
mouth and Jim is forced to reveal that
yes he met loud mouth on a science forum
though yes Jim does know loud mouth but
Jim has never met loud mouth in person
and they over the Internet but how does
crush know about Jim and loud mouth fast
we have no idea until the very end of
this chapter Jim finally responds to
laces inquiries about crush knowing this
information and says to lace privately
sorry for the delayed response lace but
there's something you should know
crush knows about me and loud mouth
internet dating because he used to be a
member of the same online science forum
there's a lot we don't know about that
kids be careful lace
Wow technology is dangerous you guys
know it's not it's safe and wonderful
AT&T
but before lace gets that text from Jim
everyone has rushed to the computer lab
because they're told that there's a
message for them there from loud mouths
and when they get there written on the
whiteboard is indeed a message I have a
certain yellow fruit in my possession a
banana your friend banana in case there
was any confusion
I will return her but only in exchange
for you text the group when you're ready
to turn yourself in and die okay thanks
bye I mean this villains got personality
and banana everything that everyone
wants so this way we find out that
loudmouth is indeed our hacker villain
but we do not know what they look like
which brings us to this week's challenge
this week we're playing these because
this week lighting is a huge deal when
it's bright everyone's positive when
it's dark no one has any idea what's
going on I am challenging you guys to
blindfold yourselves and take 60 seconds
to draw what you think loud mouth looks
like and I'm gonna do it right here
right now my highlighters my paper and
my blindfold I don't look stupid do i
okay
ready uh-huh
okay that was quite a challenge let's
see what I chose loudmouth to look like
oh wow I mean you never want to explain
your art because art is to be
interpreted individually but I was
actually trying to go for like a bushel
of grapes oh let me find this cuz this
is important fan now you know that was
that the actual time no no I just went
again oh sure
submit your lights out loud mouth
challenge art by clicking the link in
the description
it's a tumblr link for all of your fan
art we'd love to see it and we'll see
some of yours in the video next week so
here's a rat in freak week right now
crash is suspicious of Jim Jim is
suspicious of crash banana has been
taken and loud mouse is our villain
mastermind that is trying to use
satellites to exploit climate change for
evil which brings us to our prompts for
Chapter six this week we want there to
be an IRL confrontation with loudmouth
we want to find out who loud mouth is
and we want them to be confronted face
to face or faced or whatever they have
as a face we also don't know who that
mouth is we won't find out who'll a
mouth is right the other thing we want
you to include this week is a monologue
moment from one of our characters that
is not lace we just want that very
emotional poignant monologue moment to
the group that reveals something
whatever that is is up to you also
obviously you have to decide what's
happening in the world on freak week day
six it can be any
and that's it for this episode of
writing with great it has been so fun to
read all of your submissions thank you
so much for continuing to submit what's
extra fun is that we've already started
casting some of the parts that will be
read aloud at VidCon so let us know if
you guys are coming to VidCon and if you
plan on coming to see the live
performance of freak week who do you
think and your like dream of dreams
would you want to cast as each character
in freak week we've already started
casting but we need your ideas to
continue the process so good job taping
fy'y I don't know